this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream a great subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals trust me
when i say that this is content you're
going to want to see if you like content
about virginia woolf you might like to
hear john green explain her novel to the
lighthouse or if you're looking for
something a bit more explosive how about
50 episodes of war in european history
as explained by john green evidently
john green has some spare time on his
hands in between all of those books and
everything else that john green somehow
does curiosity stream is available on
many platforms web app roku android xbox
one smart tvs ios chromecast amazon fire
amazon apple tv it's available worldwide
you can go to curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics for unlimited
access the world's top documentaries and
non-fiction titles and right now you
guys can use the promo code biographics
to save 25 on the cost of an annual
subscription which comes out to just
14.99 a year which is crazy cheap so
click the link below or go to
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics and save 25 off right now
making it just 14.99 for the whole year
and now today's video
today's protagonist once wrote a
poignant thought about the art of
biography wondering whether the lives of
great men should only be recorded is not
anyone else who has lived a life and
left a record of that life worthy of
biography the failures as well as the
successes the humble as well as the
illustrious ironically today we will
make our best effort to capture at least
some of the successes of her illustrious
life on paper she had a head start in
life being born into a family of wealthy
intellectuals but her existence was
marred from the start by mental illness
and sexual abuse undeterred the strength
of her intellect plowed on and she
became one of the leading innovators of
modernist literature this is the life of
virginia woolf
[Music]
the baby who would become author
virginia woolf was born align virginia
steven on the 25th of january 1882 in
hyde park gate london her family
background was rather illustrious her
grandfather said james steven had
authored the bill to abolish slavery in
1833. her father leslie was an author
and editor founder of the dictionary of
national biography in 1867 leslie had
married minnie thackery daughter of
novelist william makepeace thackery the
two had a daughter laura in 1870 but
five years later many died of eclampsia
after three years of grieving lester
remarried with julia duckworth a model
for pre-raphaelite painters julia was
also a widower and brought her own three
children into the household stella
gerald and george leslie and julia made
it a point to overcrowd even more their
home by having four further children
together vanessa born in 1879 later to
become a painter toby born in 1880 was a
promising intellectual but he died aged
just 26. virginia and adrian in 1883 who
would become a psychoanalyst the four
steven siblings were very close and
highly gifted from an early age virginia
displayed a talent for writing stories
since the age of five penning long
serials about evil spirits lurking in
rubbish heaps as much as virginia loved
her crowded house in london her favorite
place was thailand house the family
summer getaway incentive's cornwall from
its windows she admired the views of
godrevy lighthouse towering above the
sea or enjoyed the sounds of children
playing in the terraced gardens in the
evenings she would compose short stories
in the style of nathaniel hawthorne all
those memories of sentai stayed with
virginia well into adulthood to the
point that she later wrote how her
entire life was built on that permeated
by that how much so i could never
explain virginia's love for writing and
reading drew very close to her father
the two would spend hours together
sharing books or making up stories
virginia and leslie took long walks
together during which she taught her to
dig into the more prosaic aspects of
everyday life and extract fountains of
poetic interest nonetheless leslie had
an ambivalent attitude towards the role
of women as intellectuals while he
encouraged his daughters to read write
and learn he did not believe women could
lead productive literary or artistic
careers as virginia grew older she
resented this patriarchal attitude but
she had other more problematic male
figures in her life gerald duckworth one
of her much older half-brothers had once
touched her inappropriately while on
holiday at some dives he was 18 at the
time virginia was only six this incident
left her prone to sexual fear and
instilled in her a resistance to
aggressive masculine authority this
event surely clouded the idyllicness of
her childhood but the worst was to come
when virginia entered her teens in may
1895 her mother julia died of heart
failure julia's daughter stella
duckworth took on the mantle of
surrogate mother but two years later she
too died due to complications of
pregnancy with julia and stella gone
there was no one else to keep tabs on
virginia's other half-brother george
according to virginia's own memoirs
george would visit her at night forcing
himself on her and calling her beloved
but by day he would ridicule her looks
and called her the poor goat it was too
much for a 15 year old girl to take in
september 1897 virginia first recorded
in her journal
a wish to die this diary is lengthening
indeed but death would be shorter and
less painful
virginia soldiered on but life kept
treating her like a punching bag
delivering jabs and hooks of misery
first leslie died in march 1904.
understandably the 22 year old virginia
suffered a mental collapse which led to
her attempting suicide by jumping out of
a window she recovered thanks to violet
dickinson a friend of the late stella
varla was older wise and kind just the
type of motherly figure the young
virginia needed val nursed her back to
health physically and mentally along the
way the two developed a friendship which
eventually became romantic during the
same eventful year virginia and her
sister vanessa moved to gordon's square
in the bloomsbury area of london this
was the epicenter of bohemian life in
london an area rife with non-conformist
intellectuals many of whom gravitated
around the stephen siblings their
friends included activist and author
leonard wolff biographer lytton strachey
artist roger fry economist john maynard
keynes and art critic clive bell who
would later marry vanessa by moving into
that milieu virginia and vanessa were
rejecting the habits and values expected
from two young ladies in edwardian
england they replaced polite small talk
with discussions about politics and
literature or shopping trips with visits
to art galleries and during the summer
of 1905 virginia ditched london's high
society events for long walks across
cornwall's countryside during that
period she kept a diary which became the
origin of her later narrative
experiments in her journal virginia
described how she abandoned the
well-trodden roads to venture into
barely visible paths ignoring the
artificial barriers imposed by man on
nature these ramblings were an early
metaphor for her later works in which
the narrative ignored the artificial
signposts imposed by traditional plot
lines a character's birth a marriage
someone's death virginia would instead
explore apparently insignificant moments
in time which nonetheless can shape
someone's life virginia's own life
however was to be shaped by the tritest
of plot points the death of another
character in 1906 older brother toby
succumbed to typhoid while traveling in
greece this event appeared to ignite a
steady decline in virginia's mental
health although initially she did her
best to remain mentally active and
productive while working as a teacher in
a night school for workers in south
london she composed her first short
story phyllis and rosamund the plot was
inspired by virginia and vanessa's own
experiences in london's upper middle
class milo or better it explored the
question what would happen to two
intelligent and ambitious sisters should
they not have escaped from that
environment the answer was they would
have been trapped in a lifeless limbo
like hazy figures in the background of a
party two non-entities little more than
decorative props waiting for someone to
marry them and yet virginia felt that
even this state of non-existence so
common so typical of the era was worth
recording unlike a protagonists virginia
pretty much stood out from the
background getting involved in the big
political issues of the time such as the
campaign for women's rights and suffrage
but eventually her mind deteriorated and
in july of 1910 virginia was committed
to burley sanatorium in twickenham she
absolutely loaded the experience writing
to vanessa that she saw jumping out of a
window is there any way out this extreme
means of escape was not necessary
however and virginia was dismissed after
less than two months upon a release
virginia moved into a new house in
brunswick square bloomsbury sharing
lodgings with her brother adrian and
other friends leonard wolff was one of
them and he was interested in becoming
more than just a friend the two got
engaged and eventually married on august
10 1912. leonard was a positive presence
in virginia's life he helped her cope
with the belts of mental illness and
coached her into writing her first novel
the voyage out but the relationship was
not entirely a bed of roses leonard
could not or would not consider
virginia's sexual fears and history of
abuse he even considered her to be a
sexual failure from her side virginia
had no qualms in offending leonard's
background introducing him as a
penniless jew the adjustment to married
life and tensions that came with it may
have pushed wolfe into a period of
depression in 1913. her doctor sent her
back to burley for another summer in the
abyss when virginia walked out she was
suicidal on september 9th she consulted
with two distinguished psychiatrists dr
morris wright and the aptly named sir
henry head all they could advise was a
third admission to burley something that
virginia could not swallow what she did
swallow instead was a massive dose of
bobituards she barely survived thanks to
leonard and dr head who arrived at the
right time and pumped her stomach whilst
recovering she threw herself into
finalizing the voyage out published in
march of 1915. the novel lays out some
of the main themes that wolff would
explore in later work such as the
stifling condition of married women in
early 20th century britain the voyage
out was well received by critics but it
was not a best-seller moreover the
stress associated with its publication
led virginia to suffer another mental
breakdown a violent episode of
incoherent screaming followed by a
comatose state this was followed by
another admission at burley the medical
staff tried to persuade leonard and her
family that virginia's sanity had gone
worn out by neuroasthenia or nervous
exhaustion contemporary psychiatrists
tend to agree that she was beset by
bipolar disorder instead driven by both
nature and by nurture mental illness ran
in her family granddad james suffered
from cyclothymia which causes intense
mood swings he had been
institutionalized after running naked
through cambridge and he died in an
asylum her dad leslie was also
cyclothymic while her mom julia suffered
from depression her siblings and
half-siblings were not immune either
laura leslie's daughter from his
previous marriage suffered from an
undefined psychosis vanessa and adrian
had cyclothymia 2 and the unfortunate
phobia experienced hypermanic episodes
virginia's already fragile mental state
was further compromised by the traumatic
experience suffered since childhood the
series of deaths in the family and the
vile sexual abuse perpetrated by the
darkworth boys and yet it would be
reductive to identify virginia woolf
with a mental health condition her
vitality resilience and sheer willpower
would not allow her to succumb to
institutionalization she would not
accept to lead a life defined by malay a
life adrift driven by the storms of
mania or the dead calm of depression
against all medical opinion by november
1915 virginia had recovered and was
ready to leave burley after 20 years of
half-life she was ready to throw open
the curtains and take on the most
productive period of her life
after virginia's recovery leonard was
still worried that the effect of writing
would cause her to have another
breakdown and looked for a distraction
for her as virginia had an interest in
printing and binding books by hand he
ordered a hand printing machine this
activity started as a hobby but soon it
became a business hogarth press the
wolves initially used hogarth press to
publish their own works this was a
relief for virginia who dreaded
submitting a manuscript to the prong
eyes of editors and publishers soon they
expanded their catalogue to include
small and experimental works likely to
be rejected by commercial publishers
these included writings by their friends
iam foster and john mayne at keynes but
also by sigmund freud and t.s eliot in
1919 virginia released her short story q
gardens via hogarth press the story
contrasts the aimless meandering of
eight characters against the purposeful
march of a snail and attracted the
attention of the times literary
supplement the favorable review led to
hundreds of orders and commercial
success so much so that leonard and
virginia had to forego the hand printing
press and hire a commercial printer
while hogarth press was taking off
virginia was completing her second novel
night and day published in october of
1919. wolff explores again the theme of
women who struggle to achieve their full
potential locked in a society who
accepts them only as wives and daughters
the main character catherine actively
opposes her emilio of upper class
intellectuals first by embracing
mathematics instead of poetry and then
by rejecting the courtship of a poet as
she pursues the love of an upstart
solicitor night and day was the first in
a series of writings in which wolf
shaped the defining characteristics of
the modern novel she introduced the
principle that writers did not need
sensational events to propel a story or
develop a character an ordinary mind on
an ordinary day was worthy of being
narrated in a novel she aimed to capture
the moments of being these ordinary
minds climatic inward events or
epiphanies that may strike her
characters while they conduct the most
mundane activities morph adopted these
principles in a follow-up novels jacob's
room of 1922 and mrs dalloway published
in 1925. the latter novel takes place
over a single day in june a concept
inspired by jane's joyce ulysses mrs
clarissa delaway roams london looking to
buy flowers for a party that she's
throwing she's renowned amongst london's
high society as bright and a lively
hostess although she is not entirely
satisfied with her own life clarisse's
urban travels are mirrored by her
internal meanderings as she questions
the meaning of her own existence and
reminisces about her first love peter
and about her lone homosexual experience
wolff then introduces the second main
character septimus warren smith a world
war one veteran afflicted by shell shock
smith is plagued by hallucination by an
inability to feel emotions and worst of
all by poor medical treatment the two
never meet but during the party clarissa
overhears a guest telling how septimus
committed suicide earlier that day by
jumping out of a window despite this
tragic revelation the novel ends on an
optimistic note by reflecting on
septimus's suicide clarissa finds a new
interest in the beauty of life and
reconnects with former love peter many
contemporary critics and readers
consider mrs dalloway as wolff's best
novel but it's a close tie with a
follow-up title to the lighthouse
published in may 1927. the book is
divided into three sections the window
time passes and the lighthouse the first
section the window takes place over a
single day the ramses are at their
holiday home on the isle of skye stand
in for the stevens's own retreat in
cornwall one of the children james is
planning a boat trip to a lighthouse but
his father talks him out of it claiming
bad weather the second and shorter
section time passes covers 10 years of
events including world war one during
this period the ramsey house a symbol
for civilization rots away abandoned the
house was left the house was deserted it
was left like a shell on a sand hill to
fill with dry salt grains now that life
had left it in this section wolff
hastily introduces the death of
important characters as quick edits in
between square brackets our favorite
example is a shell exploded 20 or 30
young men were blown up in france among
them andrew ramsay whose death
mercifully was instantaneous in the
final section the lighthouse james
finally completes his trip to the
lighthouse 10 years after originally
planned as with many of wolff's novels
it's difficult to pinpoint a single key
theme the more evident ones are the
nature of time and how patterns of delay
repetition and inaction can affect one's
life despite its complexity the novel
was well received by critics and readers
much to the surprise of the author on
june 6 1927 she noted in a diary they
don't laugh at me any longer possibly i
shall be a celebrated writer
[Music]
the celebrated writer defied all
expectations with the next work orlando
a biography of 1928. almost fantasy in
tone the novel features the titular
character who switches gender at a whim
and lives through centuries of british
history the novel defies the traditional
linear concept of time as the
protagonist accumulates memories each of
them becoming a wormhole transporting
her or him back to a different period
but orlando can also be read as a
fictional biography of a real life
character poet novelist and
horticulturalist vita sackville west
vita and virginia had first met in 1923
struck up a friendship and took holidays
together in france and italy virginia
idolized vita and their friendship
developed into a short romance which
became physical only on two occasions
the unstoppable wolf hit the bookshelves
again the following year with the essay
a room of one zone one of her most
celebrated feminist writings in this
work virginia addresses the pressures
which deny the intellectual and
professional development of women the
confinement to the domestic sphere
conformity to the patriarch but most of
all the inability for women to have
their own income and privacy hence the
title a woman must have money and a room
of her own if she has to ride the essay
also looks at how history is written as
a succession of wars waged by powerful
kings and generals wolff invites readers
to consider a counter-historiography
instead one focused on those women
excluded from historical records
generations of mothers and daughters who
maintained domestic order and social
peace which were regularly destroyed by
militaristic thugs the next effort was
1931's the waves virginia's most
experimental work the narrative is
structured as six soliloquies voiced by
three men and three women over a single
day they are all coping with the death
of a dear friend the characters do not
show any external expression of grief
but the author reveals their
personalities through their internal
stream of consciousness in 1932 the
writer launched into another ambitious
project which occupied her for the next
five years this was the years a family
chronicle which became wolf's
best-selling work during a lifetime here
will follows the extended pargdar family
heavily influenced by our own each
section starts with a sweeping narration
describing the sky over britain or
london in particular before zooming in
to the consciousness of a particular
character their seemingly random
activities dialogues and thoughts take
the reader through 50 years of british
history and institutions analyzing how
they've shaped the consciousness of
individuals the initial draft included a
running social commentary on the
condition of women which virginia edited
out and then published in 1938 as three
guineas the second feminist essay
identifies the dominant issues for women
of the 20th century lack of access to
education and professional advancement
if women were so excluded from the
public sphere how could they prevent the
world from slipping into another war
according to wolfe exclusion of women
led to an unbridled patriarchal society
which in turn had a direct link to the
rise of fascism in europe and thus to
the risk of international conflict that
conflict world war ii of course broke
out eventually in september of 1939.
virginia had started working on what
would be a final novel between the acts
which she continued writing under the
blitz in september of 1940 the wolf's
home in bloomsbury was bombed by the
loftwater and virginia and leonard moved
into their country home monk's house in
rodmell sussex rodmill lies a little
less than five kilometers from new haven
unbeknownst to them this was the
intended landing port for operation sea
lion the planned nazi invasion of
britain and little did they know that
heinrich himmler head of the ss had
included their names in a list of
intellectuals to be immediately arrested
while he had no knowledge of these plans
leonard feared a german landing and was
aware of the dangers for a jew and his
wife he devised contingency plans for
him and virginia to commit suicide
together an idea the writer didn't like
one bit as she was still busy with a
novel but the hard work on between the
acts and the tension created by the war
were taking a heavy toll on her virginia
could feel that her mind was beginning
to falter she feared that her mental
illness would resurface violently on the
27th of march virginia wrote to a
publisher confiding that she was not
satisfied with her current draft and she
aimed to revise it later in the year did
she really plan to continue working on
her latest novel we only know that the
following day she did pick up pen and
paper but to leave a note for leonard
dearest i feel certain i'm going mad
again i feel we can't go through another
of those terrible times and i shan't
recover this time around 11 45 am
virginia will filled her pockets with
stones walked into the fast current of
the rivers and let herself drown her
body was recovered only on the 18th of
april leonard buried her ashes in their
garden under one of the two elms with
interlaced branches they had called them
leonard and virginia
so i really hope you enjoyed today's
video sort of tangential events going on
in this series world war one and world
war ii and i have a new channel called
war of graphics which covers some of the
biggest battles and wars from history so
if you'd like to learn more about the
background of today's video please do go
check out that channel it's linked below
and thank you for watching
you